what are the first things an editor
should do in setting up a new project or
a new timeline
well communicate with your assistant
and uh sort of lay out
a plan with your assistant on how you
like things done
uh and um
you know basically when you're starting
a film you
you show them how you like
your project structured and how you like
things laid out
and after that it's pretty much cutting
you know
i have a certain way that i like my bins
laid out so i can start looking through
the material
and now of course uh
you know i've sort of been on this uh
this bandwagon this
preaching uh circuit of you know
there's so much material nowadays on the
last film that i did we had
almost 200 hours of source material
for a 90-minute comedy and
you know organization is really
key it's always been key but um
there are ways to organize that kind of
volume of footage
with markers and comments
and keywords and avid has an amazing
tool called script sync which
you can essentially catalog
every word that's spoken in dailies
and access that at any point in time
very quickly uh
search functions things like that um so
it's
all those sort of elements that you work
out with your first assistant
when you're starting a film when you're
about to get your first couple of days
of dailies or whatever
and you know you if if it's the first
time you've worked with that person
it'll take a you know you know a week or
so to kind of get
finely oiled and and and humming
but uh you know that's that's in terms
of laying out a project
in terms of cutting a scene or laying
out a timeline
[Music]
i just start watching the film and then
when i see something that
i really like i'll i'll pull that aside
and uh
i'll throw it into the timeline and you
know quite often i can i
i might even start from there i mean if
if it's if it's a nice reading from the
middle of the scene i'll just put it in
there and then maybe i'll
keep cutting from that part of the scene
or then go back and fill in the
beginning
it's pretty non-linear you know i'm
i'm not the most organized person so
it's great to have a great assistant
and i like to work uh off of my instinct
so uh yeah that's how i kind of like do
it
and so let's suppose within those 200
hours
you're looking for a scene where the
main actor said the color red
or something so you would go into the
search function
and type in red and then it would comb
through all those 200 hours and
give me every wow every
take that had a comment or a keyword
or was script sunk uh or a marker
that had the word red in it so yeah it's
it's it's a pretty
it's a pretty important part of the
process now
again metadata management
and that's why it's so important to have
assistants who are
are good at that and who like doing it
because
like for example in my last film i had a
young woman down in atlanta and she did
the script sinking that that product i
told you about
avid makes uh or it's part of media
composer but
she did the script syncing on the whole
film and essentially what she did was
transcribe all of the ad-libs and
um you know re-written dialogue and
things like that
into the machine uh you know and it's a
painstaking
chore i mean you start with the script
you can input that but then you go
through and you
have to mark the ad-lib and then you
have to mark where it is in each
take so um
[Music]
you know you really have to have people
who are you know who are like
who can focus and who are good at it
because
you're only as good as your as your
assistant script thinks it
in terms of finding material six months
down the road
yeah that's what what i was going to ask
you is so in order
would you make like a text file and you
you then it
syncs with the timeline but you have to
have someone actually
type it and then are they time coding or
they typing it
so that as it corresponds to the film
like how does it know
yeah oh i see yeah and and and you know
there are
there are shortcomings of of script sync
that you know i could get into
but frankly i'm so grateful for it i i
don't really get into it right now but
but yeah i mean you know for example
i i worked with marlon wayans on the
last film and he's an improv comedian
and he can say a line you know five or
six
times five or six different ways and
and improv it five or six different ways
so um you know just to be able to find
that reading uh it has to be transcribed
you know relatively closely and
um you know
that enables me to like get back to that
line because you know
basically the way it'll go down is the
director will say you know remember when
he said this line but he said it this
way
so in script sync you can double click
on that line or you know that take
that on that line and it'll take you
to all the material for that
line if it's script sunk properly
you